[Music]
coming up on your weekly news show is
the uk a welcoming place for people
who've had to flee their own countries
and i'm meeting one of the stars of the
new minions movie they are pretty
despicable you don't want to cross me
[Music]
hello if you want to get up to speed
with what's been going on then you've
come to the right place yep fyi has got
you covered and scarla i know you'll be
interested in this have you seen that
refugees are on the news again yeah well
the uk has been marking world refugee
week which aims to help us understand
why people become refugees and if you're
not sure what exactly a refugee is i've
been checking that out
and a refugee is someone who's had to
flee their home to seek safety in
another country because of war violence
or a natural disaster and about half of
refugees are children most recently of
course we've seen a lot of ukrainian
families come to the uk to escape from
the war in their country
i mean i saw it for myself when i was at
the border between poland and ukraine a
few months ago and i've even had a few
ukrainian students joining my class same
i've had a couple draw my cars as well
but it's not just ukrainian kids who
have come here over the years there have
been many families from lots of other
countries including iran somalia and
afghanistan
this puppet is called little amal and
she represents the plight of refugees
from syria as part of refugee week she's
been going on a tour of uk cities
including bradford manchester birmingham
and bristol and wherever she goes large
crowds follow to show their support
[Music]
but some people worry about whether too
many people from other countries are
coming into the uk and whether we can
afford to look after them all sometimes
people are so desperate to reach the uk
that they risk their lives making the
dangerous crossing between france and
england in small boats
but our government is trying to stop
this happening by saying that if they
don't have permission to be here then
they may be sent to an african country
called rwanda
it's important to know that it's not
just a uk that's been taking in refugees
one of our fyi news club members
elizabeth got in touch with us and she
wanted to tell us about the refugee
crisis in her country uganda
ifyi i as you may have heard there's a
lot of unrest and fighting in our
neighboring country the democratic
republic of congo
many congolese are fleeing the violence
and entering uganda seeking refuge
uganda is already home to over 1.5
refugees making us the top refugee
hosting country in africa and one of the
top five hosting countries in the world
we're also taking refugees from south
sudan somalia and burundi among other
countries where there is a lot of
violence
the number of refugees in uganda is
higher than some of our refugee camps
can accommodate and uganda right now is
struggling to help all those people
because of our own country's issues but
we keep our doors open to anyone who
needs help and he's seeking shelter
[Music]
thanks elizabeth and if there's
something you'd like to report on fyi
the best way is to set up an fyi news
cover at your school yeah and you can
find all our details at first dot news
fyi and tell us what you'd like to talk
about right here on fyi
now what are you like at spotting fake
news see if you can work out if this
next story is fake news or fact
[Music]
according to this online article the
united nations is warning that 500
million refugees from africa are on
their way to europe lots of people have
been commenting about it but could it
really be true
well keep watching because we'll have
the answer later in the programme
still to come on this week's programme
more dastardly deeds from those
mischievous minions
[Music]
first though do you know what this means
um no is it something to do with king
kong
no it's actually a form of sign language
called makaton and it means excited and
the reason why i'm excited is because
we're about to meet isabella who uses
makaton to communicate with her disabled
brothers
in fact her online videos have been
watched by half a million people this is
her world
hello everyone so today's sign of the
day
is milk
hi i'm isabella evans also known as
isabella signs and i do sign language
videos on social media i wanted to start
learning makaton sign language because
of my two brothers who have disabilities
makaton is derived from british sign
language it's more of a simplified
version and it's mainly used for
children who aren't able to talk yet all
have learning difficulties lucas has
down syndrome and alexander has cerebral
palsy it was really frustrating not
being able to communicate with them
properly because i could see it in their
little faces when they were trying to
tell us something and we just weren't
able to work out and they were shouting
so my
name
is lucas
lucas good job
that was good signing
lucas especially since learning sign he
is definitely a lot more confident and i
don't feel that he gets as frustrated
orange
um
orange you've gone the new draw kathmir
alexander he is also a lot more
confident the first video to ever
gain a proper lot of attraction i was
sat down with my mum's friend's little
boy who has down syndrome and we were
signing and he was copying me and doing
it back to me so my mum filmed it and
posted it just on her facebook
and it had like 30 000 views overnight
every week i do a segment on my social
media channels called a celeb sign of
the week mermaid
dragon i get a different celebrity
signing a word that's maybe relevant to
them or relevant to the time of year so
that means doctor louis tomlinson did
the sign for singer and that was the
first celeb sign i ever did and it was
amazing today's sound of the day is
singer i want lucas to be able to walk
down the street and talk to anyone he
knows happy yeah you do it
happy even just a simple like hello or
how are you i think would just be really
nice for him good job
oh that's brilliant and there's one
thing we really want to say to isabella
and her brothers you ready thomas sure
am
thank you
you are amazing
[Music]
check out this incredible footage of a
street market in thailand
there's a railway line that runs right
through the middle of it so every time a
train comes along the stall holders have
to move all their stuff out of the way
the market had to close down during the
pandemic but now the tourists are back
and so were the trains
[Music]
this month is pride month where people
from lots of different backgrounds
celebrate just being able to be
themselves it's all about being proud of
who you are but despite all the progress
that's been made in recent years but
everyone feels comfortable enough to
admit that they love people of the same
sex
one of britain's most successful
athletes dame kelly holmes has just
revealed that she loves other women
and earlier this year footballer jake
daniels became the only current player
in the english football league to tell
people that he's gay that must have
taken a lot of courage from the both of
them so we want to see what you think
hi guys thanks for joining us
so what do you guys think about jake
daniels coming out as gay considering
he's the only active uk football player
to do so
i just think it's amazing that he's done
it and because he's come out it's going
to make a lot more people feel able to
do so considering that someone's so
popular and in football which is a
popular sport that someone was able to
do it and supported well he's only 17
and at that age coming out is quite a
brave thing to do he is very
inspirational in doing it and i hope
loads of other people
find inspiration
in him doing that so recently dame kelly
holmes has come out at the age of 52. so
why do you think she didn't sooner
before becoming an olympic runner back
when she was in the army being part of
the
lgbtqia plus community was illegal and
you could be locked up for it so i guess
the idea of that being illegal was sort
of like imprinted in her i feel like you
know especially now it's you know we've
got a lot more acceptance now she's
realized society won't judge her and her
supporters will still be her supporters
do you think attitudes have changed or
is there still more to be done for gay
people to achieve equal rights yeah i
think there is quite a lot more to be
done because in some countries it's not
accepted
some countries don't have the same
rights people need to
realize that people
love who they love nobody chooses really
who they love
you've only got one life
and you need to live it how you want to
thank you guys so much for your comments
bye
thank you bye bye
one other big thing i spotted in the
news this week is extreme weather yeah
well we've got some pictures here
actually these fires have been happening
in spain but there have also been
problems in germany and america because
of how hot it's been it's pretty
worrying isn't it we're not even at the
height of summer and we've already got
these extreme temperatures scientists
are saying that much more of this is
going to be happening because of climate
change i think we're only going to see
more of this
now if you're looking for a bit of fun
over the summer holidays then how about
the new minions movie i've been to meet
one of the stars to find out what we can
expect all right who let the kid in long
before he becomes the master of evil gru
played by steve carell it's just an
eleven and three-quarter-year-old boy
plotting to take over the world
pretty despicable you don't want to
crush me
i just saw the film and it was really
funny i got from start to finish and
there were new characters as well as old
when i do these it usually takes like
two years and then i get to see it at
the end
i can't believe what they what they made
out of it yeah and they make it into
something so funny and so special
now the film is set in the 70s so i've
got your toy which was invented in the
70s and by the end of our chat you can
do as best as you can i'm a wizard these
i don't even have to look
i so wish that i had one of these like
that was all done
at the end of the interview and i just
do this the entire time
and then at the end of the interview i
go
and it looks like magic now you are
known as one of the most despicably
nicest and funniest guys in hollywood
not true
i think it is
really
watch me but what's the most despicably
baddest thing you've done in real life
okay are you ready for this
my i have three older brothers and when
my mom would make cookies the first
person who got to the cookies would try
to hide as many cookies as they could
so
so my brothers wouldn't
get too any of the cookies and they'd
come down and say what what's going on
man
so yeah that was pretty despicable of me
i think not really now i heard that to
get the voice of gru you practiced with
your family to get it right yeah until
you made them laugh well see gru doesn't
gru isn't even like a real accent i just
wanted to be a mixture of all these
different
types of personas and nationalities and
i almost wanted it to sound like a guy
who wanted to sound threatening but
really wasn't you know someone who just
kind of make you laugh when they started
to get like angry or threatening i think
we all know people like that i've had
teachers in in my life that they're like
what is the wrong matter with you and
and as they as they get angry it makes
you laugh even more because you know
they're a softy and that's that's kind
of what i wanted him to be like and
that's my last favor for you to do today
yes could you say one line in the film
in gru's accent your favorite line in
the film no i want i want you to try a
little group so say something with me
kevin
get in here
what's the matter with you kevin
now you're trying
kevin get in here
was that right yes what is the matter
with you kevin
what is that
i can't do it
that was perfect that was great well
thank you so much steve for talking to
me and i did it it's been a pleasure
likewise
[Music]
that looked like a lot of fun yeah steve
carell was so nice and he was really
funny but he didn't get very far on the
rubik's cube
now did you guys manage to work out this
week's fake news or fact
we told you about an online article
claiming that 500 million refugees are
on their way from africa to europe the
article has gone viral on the internet
but we've done a bit of digging and it's
actually fake news the un isn't warning
about a mass movement of 500 million
refugees and the article was a fake
image designed to spread misinformation
it just goes to show you've got to be so
careful to check things out
[Music]
well that's it for today but we're going
to leave you with some classical music
as you've never heard it before this is
by an italian composer called vivaldi
but it's performed by a primary school
in south africa and it's been taking the
internet by storm because it's so joyful
enjoy
[Music]
wow
[Applause]